a little surprise here a little extra
treat here Reggie Aloysius Miller a Hall
of Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst and I
noticed that reg tweeted about the UFC
229 brawl surpassing malice at the
palace and reg joins us now
hey reg Theodor how are you long time no
hear in my dad Nets a long time no hear
from well you know as if to I'm glad
this tweet kind of got sick and I he's
like
energized a little bit I was letting you
be daddy dearest daddy day care yeah I
didn't I didn't want to interrupt that
family vacations are we there yet
alright so you you were watching this
fight and you you were angry enough or
bothered by the to tweet out I wasn't
angry at all and I wasn't bothered
number one fantastic card and fantastic
fight not only the the Conor Habib fight
but the whole card was fantastic
it was just funny how the similarities
were in line with the malice at the
palace but let me start by saying this
that all the junk that Conor
Podesta Connors stick by insulting and
selling pay-per-view we've seen this
we've seen it before and when you insult
the man's faith his family his country
at the end of the day my opinions are
sticks and stones break your bones names
and over hurt me I thought Habib
should've rose above but I get where
they angry after he almost choked when
him he did choke him out because if you
watch it really closely after Conor taps
out he holds on to it an extra second
longer and then has words for Conor that
I was okay with because that was pent-up
frustration where it sets it off and it
parallels the malice at the palace is
when he jumps out of the Octagon and
goes into the stands now I hear people
saying well he was going after Connors
jiu-jitsu coach and that still doesn't
make it right
that's because he knows how to protect
himself what about the people around his
jiu-jitsu coach yeah it still doesn't
make it okay
and people say well that's boxing and in
this the case in MA you sign up for that
no you don't you look I know people when
you go to a basketball game you don't
expect it to spill over into the stands
what happened you don't expect it in
baseball well it happens hockey I know
there's fighting in hockey but you don't
expect it to spill over but it happens
and it's never okay it wasn't okay
November 19 2004 in the middle of it it
was bedlam I to this day I shake my head
on a couple of instances that went down
that day but it happened it's never okay
but I will say this the commissioner
David Stern was Swift
because we had a game the next night and
we only played with six guys if you
remember I was in a cast I had a broken
finger and I begged our trainers to cut
off my cast so I could play we only have
six guys he said the the justice was
Swift this is being kind of played out a
little bit because all we're gonna wait
for the Nevada Commission and visas
might no Dayton and white you can
control your organization and you can be
swift and it's justice because I'm
looking at being quote yeah because you
know our test was banned for the rest of
the season you had Stephen Jackson got
30 games Turner D game Jermaine O'Neal
got 25 which was down cut down to 15
Anthony Johnson got five Ben Wallace got
six I got a game bill Oh Oh Chauncey got
a game got a game yeah look Ron look
five million dollars gone for the rest
of the year
I thought the punishment was a little
too much I expected it obviously a fine
and suspensions
I didn't think Ron was going to be gone
the rest of the year because this made
me go back which I don't like to do and
look at the replays of that whole thing
hard foul was it a hard foul what forty
seconds left in the game we were up
fifteen heart foul but the overreaction
by Ben Wallace you know that that
created everything and then Ron is just
chilling on the left hand down on the
scorer's table my hand on him and that
damn cup at the corner of my eye I speed
in slow motion and then the Incredible
Hulk he from David Banner to the
Incredible Hulk and everything ensued
after that now when I've even went in to
jump the Octagon and went in you know we
still don't know because you when I was
watching it live Rogan and gang were
talking about it but they wouldn't show
the replays crazy why is that I don't
know why why wouldn't you could they
were try to sanitize it why wouldn't you
cover that you had the yeah do the
play-by-play of what's going on here yes
and I wanted to see which was a
bush-league by Habib's corner people
jumping in and the guy that was tagging
Connor from behind what come on man what
a punk move that's a punk move this man
just went four rounds yes you got beat
down
yes you got choked out but man you don't
come up from behind and tag the man a
couple of times again I understand the
frustration in the Habib corner I get it
this dude talked massive trash but
you've got you choked the life out of
him and I would have talked trash in
that octagon while they were putting the
belt on forever that should have been
his like get back but where he lost
everything is when he jumped but I get
it but at the end of the day sticks and
stones look you can't leave the field in
the field of play in this case the
Octagon you just can't do that I'm sure
there'll be a major suspension for him I
personally do not think he should lose
his belts over this he won't because the
fight was over yeah why would he had
done what he was supposed to do and he's
still undefeated and he put the
smackdown on Conor but I think a major
suspension will be coming down but guess
what I'm gonna pay for Conor Abebe too
won't you yeah there's great
or this is this is great promotion for
two it'll happen just like I thought
Connor was going to be banned from the
Octagon after in April after throwing
the dolly through the bus I thought
there ain't no way they're bringing this
dude back that sells tickets yeah
yeah I I think they could suspend him
for six months but all that means is he
doesn't fight for six months and then
and then he comes back after six months
in one day and then he's ready to fight
Conor McGregor again he's not gonna lose
his belt say you know they may find him
you know a million dollars or something
and and they move on I believe his purse
was two million for the fight and I
think they'll probably hope you're right
they'll probably hold him million back
maybe five hundred thousand a million
but I think he'll get some of this first
because the work was already done he did
put it in the work yes they do he took
the life out of them but you cannot
leave you can't leave the feel to play
you can't but look the other day you're
talking to a smack talker I get it
I absolutely get it this dude was
talking so much trash you know the
weigh-ins putting hands on me I get it I
get it but you had that when you were
choking him out and herb Dean after he
tapped out and was trying to grab you
and you held on that extra two seconds
that was your justice right there when
you got up and you were talking noise to
him that was your justice leave it at
that when Joe Rogan comes into the ring
and interviews you that's when you're
smacked
that's when you should have like let it
all out but when you jump the Octagon
and you go in and I don't want to hear
that's his jiu-jitsu coach and he knew
how to handle himself what about the
other people around them what about the
officers that had to run in what if they
would have got a stray elbow we don't
know because they won't release the
footage it's right here to you they'll
pump you some lawsuits coming down from
some fans who say they got hurt in the
melee right it could be could be yeah I
haven't heard anything but there could
be there could be some photo injuries
there wait right someone's just trying
to you know capitalize and everyone
saying you know cuz I heard Stephen a
say this and I love what Stephen a most
of the times too
but on this point when he said that no
one really got hurt in the April
incident from Connor throwing that two
fighters could not fight that night
because of stitches yeah that's their
livelihood so someone did get hurt you
know no one really got hurt no someone
did get hurt
two P two fighters who came to fight
that night could not fight because of
stitches because of the actions of Conor
McGregor
he's Reggie Miller please dig it hurt
the Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA
analyst joining us but talking MMA
are you watching preseason NBA of course
what should we be watching for really
the story is going to be out of 29 other
teams who can dethrone the champ in my
opinion can the Lakers actually put up a
good fight against Golden State
no no what about for months I have them
think III will say this this sounds good
I think Golden State is going to be I
would take 237 in the West form an
all-star team out of 237 and they still
not might not be able to be gonna stay
in the West especially when boogie
custom comes back because what you did
by adding boogie cousins you added a
ballistic missile a guy that has to chip
on the shoulder a guy that throughout
his career people say it could be
untamed has an attitude but now you add
him to Steve Kerr and that locker room
and to draymond Green and Steph Curry in
that winning culture and on ring night
well he has to go in the back while
after guys celebrate that's going to
feel his fire
I want to be a part of that I want one
of those so that adds energy to guys
that have won three in the case of you
know Steph and klay and dream on and two
for KD you know it says I'm getting
bored you have new life new energy in
that locker room so that's what barring
injury major injury
because they had injury last year
definitely played what 5455 games and
they still want barring major injury I
just don't see it in a seven-game series
anyone being able to do beat them do I
think some teams can compete with them
absolutely Boston can compete with them
in my opinion that might be it even
Houston might be it no if Andre Iguodala
does not get hurt last year I don't
think that goes seven games I don't
think that's a seven game series people
forget he was hurt that whole series or
the last three or three games I believe
you got the Lakers 50 wins I do not I
have them in the finishing six in the
West and I have them anywhere between 45
to 49 wins if they get 50 wins if they
get 51 wins LeBron James will once again
be in strong consideration for MVP and
Luke Walton should be coach of the year
if they get 51 wins or more I'm just I'm
the makeup of the rosters weird reg that
you got the young guys I like it I like
it I love the Rondo pick up I love Rondo
because Rondo won't pay off until April
and May and I think he's going to help
Lonzo understand the game of basketball
because Alonzo has great potential and
great talents and to me he just doesn't
understand the game Rondo is a
basketball savant so I think that will
help them and you've got to play them
together but Rondo old pail pay off
until playoff time we saw what he did
for Chicago before he broke his hand
they should have be Boston a couple
years ago and we saw last year what he
did for New Orleans when they beat
Portland swept them in the first round
he is a basketball savant obviously
winning the championship under Doc
Rivers playing with you know kg ray and
Paul I think it's gonna pay off big-time
come playoff time with Rondo yeah but 45
wins 249 I think and being number six in
in the West I think
I have Denver ahead of them Utah Houston
Golden State and OKC you know I think it
comes down to this and I hate to single
out one guy but I I know what to expect
from LeBron Kuzma I think Brandon Ingram
needs to take that next step towards
being being great or you know close to
being great I don't know if if he's
capable doing it I don't know if the
shadow of LeBron helps her hurts but I
look at Ingram as the guy who might be
really the key if they're going to be a
dangerous team this year what do you
think if this training camp is any
indication because they've both played
well together a few days ago he had 31
points in the start playing alongside
LeBron James so if this training camp in
this exhibition season is any indication
that's a positive move or Laker nation
because they're finding ways to coexist
and you're absolutely right because to
me he's the x-factor because if he plays
towards the potential that we all
believe that he has and he's capable of
playing with then maybe this is a 50-win
team but I just think on a nightly basis
there's gonna be a lot of inconsistency
with those young guys and once again I
think LeBron is going to have to carry
the load especially early I think they
will struggle early I think they will
find their footing the middle of
December probably through the all-star
break and then they may falter off a
little bit March into April and struggle
not necessarily to get into the playoffs
but they're not that 50-win team in
Lakers to me the Lakers really are on
the clock not this season but next
season because they ought to get another
proven true free agent blockbuster deal
and there's a play alongside LeBron and
these other young guys and then they're
really on the clock it's good to hear
from you we'll check in with you when
regular season storm so it's the hope
the family is good and we appreciate you
calling in family is fantastic fantastic
I miss you guys this is great I love our
energy
[Music]
baggie wrench for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]